no Jason Jason Jason Focus it's finally
reached Beantown then now SP from Oldman
silver everyone's been talking about as
the sunsets on the great LeBron the time
has come to find a new face of our
league which one of you will prove your
word hey you know be a wicked good face
of the league modern day Larry Bird oh
yeah yeah yeah
how quickly they forget about you being
selfish won't win us a ring of influence
you're only saying that because we got
embarrassed it's a troll worse it's a
[Music]
Joel
[Applause]
remember my game plan Joel no need to
charge
spacing to much should I get an MVP for
a trash talker I thought there weren't
many of this kind left Jason I need you
to oh no and got in his
head rent
free if I took him out I could be the
face of the league imagine every man
woman and child wearing a jayen brown
jerse The
Traveler maybe I'm not him Jason you're
him it's your team be selfish be
selfish be
selfish I haven't seen this in years
it's Mamba mod stop
him goodbye traveler one day you won't
disappear when we all need
you I can't lose I'm the best center in
the
league too bad is a Wings League
now come back
[Music]
jimy I told you to take out that blimp
hey look I did shoot a power ball like
all summer Gentlemen We Will Remain the
face of the game but we must do
everything we can to stop them leave no
stone
unturned before they
become too
[Music]
powerful I'm back on
top okay you've had your shot it's my
time now Luca if anyone's taking the MVP
item from yits it's the winner of last
use one seat and how'd that work out for
you
huh wow the wonders of This Strange Land
never cease to
amaze you guys
[Music]
coming oh man yic does everything for
1.6 km high city this is why an elite
fighter like you or me must stop him
from getting a third Idol oh so you're
on giannis's level now
[Music]
okay this is the closest I've been to a
real trophy don't y's MPS are
R oh another Yannis
wall Point God show me the way huh
Chris
DeAndre I will I am used to being
alone he's here
hello here we
go stop hiding the MVP away in the
mountains it belongs in a bigger Market
guys are we really doubling in open
combat almost
ready I've have many weapons in my
Arsenal in the back what does
that
wait can it's where I am without looking
I don't know if I can beat him without
help I've been here for the hey man this
place is very
nice I will not be cooled
off you had one job Joker the
associations dis place
pleased you know I live
online Channel your raid at stopping
fees
[Music]
targets miss out of his traft class oh
and dyl Brook man I haven't seen grit
City this happy since we switch gas
hopefully I can be a good face of the
league for
everyone what's going
on
Zion he's got a new
body oh no I got with clothes on
run why is everyone so excited about
Zion he hasn't really done
anything Dylan get the Gritz to
safety according to the overly detailed
diagram in my head nothing can stop Zion
once he gets through the
perimeter don't worry there's strength
in
[Music]
numbers
I still remember your
weakness even his kicks have changed
time to get
flashy the association is controlling
him Bion it's not just you against me
this is bigger than that remember the
code Zion let's promise to always be
best friends promise now let's go
destroy some fellow
[Music]
children the
code spoiler alert I was in there the
whole
time thanks bro they really tried to pit
us against each other those old Heads
Stay controlling the narrative we got to
fight back follow
me once J and Zion take each other route
nothing will be in our
way yeah
nothing
are we sure we want to activate him the
association headquarters in the
Hollywood to attack them where it
hurts the rising young stars are finally
fighting the old heads they're even
taking down some legends from within
their own ranks there's no doubt a new
class of Heroes has risen up it ain't no
way LeBron and do BU friers taking out
them kids take them out to dinner maybe
look at you already talking about food I
know you not talking all you talking
about is barbecue chicken at least I got
Rings thank you to the Salt Lakes for
welcoming us to all Hero weekend as a
special treat taverns will be open till
8:00 p.m. I've never got so many cheers
I'm so excited why is Steph here
everyone knows I was brought in to
replace him
he thinks he can replace me cute look
LeBron's cour in the second hot as young
guard but King you already have DLo
LeBron step away from the impressionable
young star thanks Dame I almost had to
go to a place with pressure and
expectations I've battled too many super
teams some less super than others and I
vow no super teams will form this all
Hero weekend not this loyalty it
[Music]
again
H I've used it many times it's never
failed me
Lebron a did I ruin another one of your
trades maybe it's me or maybe it's you
I know you think you
clutch I'll show you clutch Dam calm
down you're not supposed to activate it
not at all Hero weekend welcome back to
the celebrity all Hero game post balone
struggles down the court and oh nice
being this Dame time may God have mercy
on us
all
no more hand covering mouth Whispering
thing BS
away I knew this would happen before I
came here I I knew this would happen 16
balls dang you're right about super
teams everyone should follow the old
ways of heartbreaking losses huh oh
sorry Dame you were destroying the Salt
Lakes and none of us want to be a part
of that
rebuild wow best all Hero weekend yet
nice bag of tricks you got there whoa
careful no super
teams I've used it many times it's never
failed
me all H the be H the beam you may be
benched worshippers of the beam it has
been my pleasure to Shepherd in a
triumphant New Era where with every
Victory the beam grows stronger all hail
the beam tonight we shall summon the
almighty beam allowing us to blot out
the Western sky with its beauty never
again will sack down be thrust Back Into
Darkness an
intruder it can't be the prodigal son
has returned Tyrese I've come to shut
off that damn
[Music]
be you ready for that sweet
revenge I'm just focused on passing
right now but
yes
[Applause]
brother halber have you come to embrace
the
beam that's rude very well beam grant us
the power of the pistol
offense think Corner
Shooters
buddy no one shoots f faster than
me wait I knew I don't know what I'm
doing I'm getting too old for
this I'm too young for
this nothing like homemade red
[Music]
velvet like the be now we summon the
almighty be
you're in my spot
run there are no spots in the eyes of
the
beam look into the beam Tyrese
never
[Music]
no
yo the beam I go by many names some call
me the almighty beam some call me stupid
and
ironic I hear you've come to destroy me
why I wanted revenge for being cast out
and to prove to everyone I'm not a fake
hero Ali serak is everyone
now you are a hero here and you are hero
in indianaoplis just because the beam
shines doesn't mean you don't shine
you need to find your own be find my own
[Music]
be you ready for that sweet
revenge where are you
going that's someone else's problem
let's find our own
me I was not expecting that answer to be
that deep you good
bro
the be from the north is too powerful we
must offer up a sacrifice to protect the
C oh wa W
[Music]
hey collapse there is no
collapse we can make this work just
shoot us an opening
bit I
can't
I figured this moment would come you
figured this moment would come you
brought me here I did what I was
supposed to do Kyrie no don't leave me
with these
scrubs luckily you were able to join
this super team right so is this like
y'all's downtown or no this is the Nash
path the quickest way to the tournament
and where I can finally beat
him that's them all right Lucas's
carrying all the weight attack
look
out oh you it's just the Suns thought it
was rest thank
you
wait it's
Kyrie and he's actually planning on
[Music]
participating Kevin you must relax relax
there's no relax CH I'm on
TI okay and what's the game play
look I'm not the Savior here I'm
watching just like everyone
else good thing it's just my sons hello
book it's Daddy
LCA totally legitimate Warriors ring
[Music]
go hey y' are shooting more than me
DeAndre not fair I don't want to be here
hm looks like the odds are even uh you
and your numbers too hot too handles oh
illegal Powerball he took three steps
doesn't
count man snitch well I've done my
[Music]
rooll come on Rust I mean Ste I mean
Kyrie I mean
book you handle Kevin I've got this ah
isolation chamber
hey you started it no you started it ow
my
groin I can't believe what you said
you'll have to be more specific you said
you did what you were supposed to do did
that include betraying your best
friend you don't have to answer your
silence speaks volumes Easy Money
mid-range invisible
Defender
[Applause]
[Music]
a Kyrie no don't leave me with these
scrubs don't you see I saved you I saved
you
because I may want to join the Suns next
year no Kyrie not again I mean well
maybe if you but no come on for some
reason the masth have been terrible
since I got here I mean yeah but
what while they focus on their lethal
rivalry the number one seed can go
straight to playoff
[Music]
Mountain woo ni playoff Mountain we
going from the base camp to our face on
a stamp J Bing Bong yeah we still do
that hello it's your cool dad Adam
Silver welcome to the Eastern face of
playoff Mountain each team will Traverse
their own path finding opponents on
their way to the summit where the
champion will take on the best of the
western face please make your way to
your assigned path hell yeah I'm hyp
let's go chill bro the strongest Heroes
of the East Lands are all
here
on your mark get set
Ball slow down if we get lost I'm going
to get blamed and sent away relax I was
brought here to guide you I I think we
need to go I'm doing things by
way maybe we should turn around Paul
George writes that everywhere let's find
our first
opponent come out and fight looks like
we got a
buy
[Music]
uh uh
guys looks like the only thing stopping
us from playoff success is
[Music]
ourselves all right here's what we do I
take out all three Julius slow down the
pace necessary spin move unnecessary
spin move
the shadow Knicks have all our moves
including our flaws which means Shadow
RJ shouldn't be able to shoot from there
hey not
[Music]
true careful spikes I put up with a lot
but this is the next team that finally
bakes
me every year it's something I knew we
shouldn't have given up already
maybe no your is next town too
far you're
under I'm the same height as Donovan
Mitchell you can't defeat us we're the
Nicks we're already ready to and we got
B more deis than anyone else here stay
up friend
too much pressure I'm
out collapsing the crun time the Knicks
are so
predictable predictable these Knicks now
Julius
jump
piss he let his Fe that should never
work oh you can't esve me forever I have
facial recognition software a looks like
your plan worked all we needed was some
heart sorry I'm late on
guard ah it's justtin Knicks this should
be an easy fight trust us it's harder
than you think who will reach the top of
playoff mountain and lay claim to the
new face of the league H if I know I
just know they get paid a hell lot more
than when I was a hero also my playoff
prediction wizard the great BR Bill win
it all shut up Chuck I'm trying to wrap
up the season uhoh
rebound not the face my
endorsements once every
generation a new star
arrives undesirable destination
[Music]
confirmed and everyone prepares for him
shaum
ois he can turn another young star into
a second
fiddle you can build something out of
all those bricks you've been piling
up you could restart a fan base's
engine
finally
answer all your tough
questions he could even stop the
greedy from
hoarding and
maybe just maybe he could stop our
drought
B which lucky Souls have Wy wimby
Lottery and if he doesn't land here I
mean I'll take a flyer on scoot I don't
care I'm going to live
[Music]
forever